[Music]
well hello I'm McGowan and welcome to
Cadogan Hall in London for an
intelligence squared debate or on
democracy that's a word which means many
things to many people around the world
different nations different leaders
political systems they talk of being
democratic when what they want and mean
can sometimes be anything but take North
Korea's elections in recent days a 100
percent vote for Kim jong-un in the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
calling a referendum at breakneck speed
as in Crimea this weekend does not
necessarily mean democracy as it should
be
and compared the faltering economic
growth of the world's largest democracy
India with that of China whose own
version of democracy has really
guaranteed rapid economic development
but not with universal suffrage so the
motion for this debate democracy is not
always the best form of government and
we have an excellent panel for you here
tonight arguing for the motion martin
Jake's author of the global bestseller
when China rules the world and rosemary
Hollis professor of Middle East Policy
Studies author of the recent article no
friend of democratization Europe's role
in the genesis of the Arab Spring
against the motion
Ian Bremmer American political scientist
founder of Eurasia group and leading
global political risk research and
consulting firm and also an Bri chef
Schenker welcome member of the Ukrainian
Parliament the verkhovna rada very close
to the former Prime Minister Yulia
Tymoshenko so dramatically released
recently from prism and acting prime
minister arseniy yatsenyuk ladies and
gentlemen your panel here in cagin all
now the opening statements from the
panel is speaking first for the motion
martin Jake's a senior fellow at
Cambridge University author of the
global bestseller when China rules the
world he is also a visiting professor at
Ching hai University in Beijing and
fellow at the transatlantic Academy in
Washington DC
please welcome Martine Jakes let me
start by saying what this motion is not
about we are not proposing that the UK
and other developed countries should
abandon democracy that would be a
nonsense and fly in the face of our
history and our tradition rather what we
are arguing is against the Western
mantra that democracy is the right and
appropriate system for all countries
whatever their circumstances after 1989
and the collapse of Soviet Communism the
Western author doxy was that democracy
was the universal panacea first of all
let's take Russia there was a widespread
expectation and belief that Russia would
develop a western-style democracy under
western-style free-market over the years
it's become clear not only is that not
true but what we've witnessed is the
reassertion of Russian history roughen
Russian traditions and Russian culture
and with that the emergence of an
authoritarian state or take Iraq you may
remember that the United States in
conjunction with Britain invaded
illegally Iraq in the name of democracy
what's happened does that that democracy
has it worked it certainly hasn't or
take Egypt the litmus paper test of the
Arab Spring where democracy briefly
sprung into life and has been killed off
by the reassertion of military power or
take China
China in 1990 was still an extremely
small economy and since then we've seen
what I would argue is the most
remarkable economic transformation in
human history and it's been presided
over not by a western-style democracy
but a different system all together the
fact is that democracy is not
universally appropriate and applicable
in all countries regardless of history
and culture and circumstances above all
the democracy fits all mentality ignores
the fundamental historical and cultural
differences between the developed
countries and the developing countries
the level of a country's economic
development is a critical issue let me
remind you that not a single Western
country was a democracy at the time of
its economic takeoff the crucial problem
facing development countries home
remember to eighty-five percent of the
world's population is economic takeoff
industrialization the shift from the
countryside to the cities just as it was
for us in an earlier era please bear in
mind too that developing countries
frequently have to contend with very
different circumstances to those that
face the West in the nineteenth century
a dominant highly competitive west bent
on pursuing its own interests often at
the expense of the developing countries
my final point concerns China the last
30 years we've seen a most extraordinary
achievement a country of 1.3 billion
people 20 percent of the world's
population growing at 10% a year one
twentieth of the size of the United
States economy in 1980 now over half the
size of the American economy
600 million people taken out of poverty
China no western-style democracy but an
extraordinary competent state over time
I believe democracy will grow but it
must grow in its own way and according
to a country's own history culture and
circumstances democracy will come in
many different forms shapes and sizes
they may learn from us that they will
not be like us thank you very much
Martin Jake's there speaking for the
motion Martin thank you very much indeed
let's go to the first speaker against
the motion
Ian Bremmer political scientist
consultant specializing in global
political risk author of every nation
for itself winners and losers in a g0
world
please welcome in Bremer thank you very
much one of the good things about not
writing a speech is it doesn't bother
you when you just want to respond to
some of the points that your colleague
makes right at the beginning the first
point so why should we tell a country to
support democracy as a system when we
didn't support democracy in earlier
stages of our developments a very good
question why should we tell a country to
respect human rights when we didn't in
an earlier stage in our development why
should we tell a country not to engage
in slavery when we didn't do that at an
earlier stage of development that's a
hard argument to swallow right it
doesn't feel good look I completely
understand that it is actually not
fashionable to take this side of the
argument but at the same time the notion
of by the people and for the people
intrinsically feels right to us
running a country being in having that
kind of power being invested in anyone
but us is problematic we don't trust
anyone with that sort of power except
maybe the Canadians we don't trust
individuals to run it without checks and
balances without legitimacy without the
ability to throw them out if they do a
bad job or when they appoint their son
since it's rarely their daughter we
don't like it that's that's one reason
I think that we should pay attention to
what we think deep down on that second
point to Martin rush and
authoritarianism no question Yeltsin
came in short-term efforts at democracy
failed I'm sure we all agree that
Putin's authoritarianism isn't much
better for Russia all right
it's not true Putin's very powerful he's
very rich he uses every mode of
conveyance I've ever seen in my life any
any transport any animal he's all over
it he looks good
to some people but but the fact is that
he's enriched himself on the backs of at
the expense of the Russian people the
brain drain has been phenomenal the
capital flight has been huge
Egypt democracy what a failure there was
no democracy in Egypt the military ran
the country we had an Arab Spring
everyone got excited how wonderful the
military never went anywhere they still
controlled the country Arab monarchies
how do we think they work do you think
they'd be better off if there was
actually more representation how would
women be treated in those Arab
monarchies a little better I think so do
we like that sure so we'd be telling
them what to do with women what do you
think the Arab women would say I know
what they'd say they like a different
system that's not the West's shoving it
down their throat I hate the idea of
American exceptionalism I don't want to
tell people how to run their system look
at the way we run our system in a
disaster the fact that the US government
today is less popular does not mean that
democracy is less pop you in America it
actually means that people want to
return to democracy in America I
completely agree with Martin that China
is the interesting case here right the
Arab states are not Russia is not it's
very clear in so many countries of the
world that they would be run better for
their people if there was more democracy
and accountability it's very clear right
in China for 35 years they've been
growing
and on average 10% a year and the
world's never seen that 1.3 billion
people that's very impressive but what
interests me in China is that they
understand that that's not sustainable
if they don't have the ability to tell
their people that there's a reason that
you vote for us besides throwing you 10%
growth every year they're in very
serious trouble because you know what
happens in an authoritarian regime when
you lose power they don't just vote you
out it's worse than that the Chinese
government the most successful
authoritarian revolution and experiment
that the world has ever seen over 35
years even they understand that if they
don't create a more democratic system
they're gone too if they recognize it
what does it mean for the rest of us
thank you very much
Ian Bremmer thank you very much indeed
now our second final speaker for the
motion Rosemarie Hollis professor of
Middle East Studies and expert on
conflict and security in the region also
director of the olive tree scholarship
program at City University here in
London please welcome resume holders
a lot of nonsense is talked about
democracy and mostly by people who live
in relatively rich Western democracies
who attribute their comparative wealth
and well-being to of course first their
own hard work second their liberal
capitalist system and thirdly their
democratic form of government in other
words the benefits of democracy are
relative it depends on who you are where
you are in the global system how wealthy
your state is compared to others and
where you are in the evolution of your
own political system now first looking
at who you are supposing you are a
member of a minority community an ethnic
or religious minority for example a
Basque separatist in Spain a Jew in Nazi
Germany a Turk in Germany how well will
majority rule protect you
democracy does not automatically do so
your safety depends on the values
espoused by the government of the day
and a populist government may win
election by playing to majority
prejudices at the expense of the
minorities why else would religious
minority communities sometimes feel
safer under dictatorial role than
majority rule the benefits of democracy
all depend whether you draw the lines on
the map around the democracy concerned
for ordinary Indians who do have a
democracy and Chinese who
not what matters is that their
government is strong enough to defend
their national corner they're not
operating in a vacuum democracy or
otherwise that's whether they have a say
in the composition of their government
is less relevant to their chances of
prosperity than the ability of their
government to exercise leverage at the
international level suppose you live in
a small underdeveloped country dependent
on investment and aid from the developed
world for you to achieve a halfway
decent standard of living and gainful
employment whether elected or not your
government will have to bow to the
dictates of multinationals and
international financial institutions
whose priorities are respectively
profits and loan repayments not your
well being your democracy is meaningless
when your government has no real power
in any case politicians are masters at
managing national perceptions
manufacturing consent even and I contend
the Western democracies mistake their
moral authority at home as a license to
tell other people how they should govern
themselves but their own systems are non
exportable do not please ladies and
gentlemen equate the word democracy with
what makes you feel good here because it
cannot work without the comparative
economic advantages that are enjoyed
here thank you
Rosalie Hollis thank you very much
indeed so we've heard the two main
voices for the motion now the final
speaker against the motion andrey
Shevchenko a former journalist turned
politician who represents the fatherland
party of Yulia Tymoshenko in the
Ukrainian Parliament he has been
described in the London Times as a
potential future leader of Ukraine here
straight from Kiev Andrey Shevchenko
I would first sure will this thing it's
a it's this constructors helmet is one
of the symbols of recent anti
dictatorship protests in Ukraine it was
supposed to protect your head from
police sticks or if you were lucky
enough from rubber bullets of course
later on helmets like this would not
protect people from snipers and from
gunmen and as you know more than 100 of
protesters died in the streets of Kiel
mostly because of the snipers bullets
and because of police grenades but if
well I have brought this helmet here and
just to remind all of us that there are
countries where people literally fight
and die for their right to live under
democracy and if you talked to my
brothers on the barricades they will be
very surprised to hear this kind of
discussion democracy for them means that
no one can govern people without their
consent democracy for them it's their
right to be responsible for their future
so people those angry men who were
wearing orange helmets orange
constructors helmets they were literally
feeling themselves felt themselves as
constructors of their future this is
what democracy is about for them it's a
very clear moral choice it's a choice
between freedom and slavery between hope
and humiliation that's what democracy is
about for them and I think we should
really keep that in mind before we go
into some more pragmatic things to
discuss
now let's do some numbers and let's talk
pragmatically here's the world list of
the richest countries by the per capita
income in 2012 only four out of top 20
countries were not democracies only six
out of top 30 countries were not
democracies and there is a clear
evidence of a correlation between
democracy and economic development and
we perfectly understand why true not all
democracies are each in fact some
democracies miserably poor but if you
build a stable democracy you have better
chances to be rich and to live in a
prosperous society we understand why
because democracy also means rule of law
freedom of entrepreneurship more
democracy generally means more
prosperity here is the United Nations
Human Development Index list of 2013 and
it's even more interesting for us
because this index is based on three
criteria its life expectancy its
education and it's the per capita income
which we have just discussed so the
Premier League of the list is called the
countries with very high human
development only 3 out of 47 countries
on the list are not democracies and that
makes sense because democracy means that
you spend wealth national wealth not
just for fancy palaces or luxury cars
for the few who are in power but you've
got to take care of the constituency
when you cast your vote in the end of
this debate I really ask you to think
about the rest of the world when you
will be making a decision please cast a
vote on behalf of protesters in
Venezuela on behalf of civil activists
in Iran on behalf of all those people
who know they will not be able to enjoy
the privileges of democracy you enjoy
why they enter their lives that's the
reason why they are ready to fight for
that that's reason why they are ready to
fight and probably die to give the
chance to their kids and to their
grandchildren so please do think about
the Ukrainians who have been fighting
for freedom of their country
for its territorial integrity and for
the better world for our loyal followers
so please vote against the motion and in
favor of democracy
I drew Shevchenko thank you very much
indeed
and for being here from Kiev now we've
heard from the four speakers for and
against the motion before I hear from
you in the audience with the microphones
I'm going to give you the result of what
you decided as you were coming in not
having listened to any of the debates so
far let me tell you that almost half of
you had not made up your minds 44
percent of you don't know what your view
is are on that this motion democracy is
not always the best form of government
but 38% of you did think that you were
for the motion and 18% were against so
there's a lot of work to be done on both
sides here to convince you let's hear
from you please stand up could I get a
lady there and a lady somewhere in the
middle there please hello this is a
question for Ian you gave a lot of
examples in your speech of sham
democracies and democracies that are
flawed I was wondering whether you could
give us an example of a good democracy
as if that's something that we all
should be working towards it would be
good to have a role model stick that up
in theirs at the back please you've got
the microphone and then move the
microphone down here please to the
gentleman here hello I was wondering if
we could have a definition of what
democracy is if it's about voting then
and for Representatives we have a 55%
unelected legislature here in the UK or
House of Lords under Queen are we a
democracy also for turnout rates
particularly among young people about
30% the last general election
15% at the last European election is
this a democracy thank you
at the back at the back there please I
am against the motion and for democracy
and I think that Ian Brenner had really
good points you know he's a very good
speaker as well but I think that a very
important point a very important point
he made was that it isn't the question
really isn't whether democracy is or
isn't the best form of government but
it's about accountability and that is
something that I think we're kind of
missing the point and it's democracy in
many countries countries can be poor and
democratic and rich and democratic it
doesn't mean that democracy is always
being like practiced but it is the best
form right so the issue about definition
of democracy which we could debate all
night but and rave when you look at what
you've been through what you're still
going through and what still lies ahead
in your country do you have a clarity
about what democracy is I think what we
might think about is we can explore some
new opportunities of democracy I think
it would be ridiculous to limit
democracy just to representative
democracy in the classic mean think
about Iceland after it went through
these terrible financial crises they had
the Constitutional Assembly
it wasn't elected in the classical way
but when people represented fishermen
teachers whoever get together if I may
say so in other words democracy is
everything that makes you feel good
democracy is something that the lady was
talking about it's really about feeling
confident I would think I would say it
would be ridiculous to limit democracy
just to mathematics and to the boat
count that's my point but going back to
Iceland so when they got together when
they were rewriting the constitution of
this country one of the first thing
which was in the document was we are
supposed to protect the earth it's
probably something which which typical
politicians would not think about in the
beginning of the Constitution so I think
new forms of democracy could provide us
with some great new forms of Garnon but
it's it's not to undermine the basic
principles we are talking about I said
at the beginning government for the
people by the people
yeah you have a queen it's true do I
think that really enjoys on
representative democracy in Britain the
House of Lords and it cost you some
money but fundamentally speaking no
there's a spectrum here look China is
more democratic than North Korea right
do we think China is more generally
respectful of civil rights to North
Korea
yeah who's farther along that spectrum
India is more democratic than China is
do we think India is more respectful of
human rights generally speaking than
China I think the answer is yeah are
there any well-run democracies out there
look Canada's more democratic than the
United States today Canada is pretty
well run the Scandinavians are more
democratic the Scandinavians are more
well-run than the United States
absolutely I think I'd say Australia on
balance is more run they're smaller it's
easier to use
efficiency well run well run as part of
the above being a democracy no no I
didn't say that at all you said they
were better than democracies because
they were well-run what does that mean
better better democracies in the sense
that they are they are governments that
are more effectively run for and by the
people they are more legitimate and seen
as more legitimate the as I mentioned
the United States has a more difficult
time today because the the the the state
has been captured to a degree by the
private sector in a way that has not in
Canada that absolutely undermines the
ability of the American government to be
seen as governed by and forth so your
argument does basically rest on ideals
not realities
but democracy certainly democracy
absolutely takes into into consideration
the ideals of the people of the country
well I mean you know I don't really know
beyond a point what your argument is
because it seems to be everything now
let's take the example of China okay
compared with any Western country at the
moment and you look at the Pew Global
Attitudes survey statistics and the
levels of satisfaction amongst the
Chinese with what's going to happen to
their standard of living the economic
competence of the government and their
outlook in terms of what the future is
going to bring is way higher than it is
in Western societies and it's not true
that you know democracies are by and
large better run than thing than things
that in our book like China aren't
democracies although of course they do
have elements of democracy
up there please you'd be very patient
and a lot of other people as well which
way you voting which way when I was that
don't now I'm afraid and I'm still I'm
still swinging in the wind but not I'm
swinging both ways but if I can offer a
handy realistic definition of democracy
you don't really know what it means
don't we the Queen's nothing to do with
it all it means is that the executive
can be held meaningfully to account
through whatever mechanism
representative or not by a large enough
body of the electorate or public and
that does seem to hand in hand with the
virtuous of liberalism which include
freedom of the individual whether or not
this takes a fully capitalist form or
not although I suspect that capitalism
is intimately linked with freedom
therefore I want to put an argument to a
dr. Holliston and dr. Jakes I hope
haven't promoted you and the argument is
if the professor I beg his pardon the
argument is this if you were to find by
some secret channel that there were
movements of thought in China to move
China decisively towards that notion of
representative democracy would you
really stand in its way
hold that thought up there please
specifically on China I just would like
to make few comments that economic
development at the barrel of a gun where
large swathes of population in China was
killed
one child policy where especially baby
girls were being abandoned or strangled
I don't think this is a good argument to
say that a form of government that has
brought some economic development also
by cooking their books most of the time
it's a good argument to say that
democracy is not always a good situation
one more review here please so I'm I'm
for democracy and for the motion which I
don't regard as a contradiction at all
thank you you're very welcome
this point may have been covered since
already but I only thought it well I'll
ask the question very quickly which is
if you guys were to form a sort of
government consultancy given the the
explosive growth we've seen in China
over the last 25 years
would you go back 25 years and recommend
to that government that they should
actually vote in a democracy all right
three questions there
Martin particularly you've got a very
short time to answer them but give as
the idea of your thoughts please there
well the first question was would I
stand in the way of the development of a
representative democracy in China no I
wouldn't if that's what the Chinese want
to do if you're suggesting that that's a
likely scenario in anything like the
next 20 or 30 years I think you're wrong
and the and linking this with the last
question the fact is that you know I
would say that probably the kind of
government they've had in China over the
last 30 years since 1980 since Deng
Xiaoping has served the Chinese much
better than for example the kind of
democracy that they've got in India it
is true it is true and that a lot of de
famille babies have been killed in China
especially in the countryside by the way
exactly the same things happened in
India this is not about democracy and
authoritarianism this is about
traditions in backwards a surprise
I'm Dre I would just add that I strongly
believe that the Edit value of democracy
is universal across the world and I I
could hardly imagine good arguments why
some countries should should be deprived
of civil rights or some what some other
basic things and in general when I hear
about some special ways for specific
country when we hear about this idea of
sovereign democracy very special way
usually it's just a cover for some very
bad things and not that good things
ruthless corruption terrible crimes and
fear of rulers rulers to lose the power
that's what that's what sometimes stands
behind those nice words let me check
hydrate let me ask you though
specifically about your country where
there's a referendum on Crimea what's
your view about that is that democratic
well we have another brilliant example
of referendum to compare the Crimean
referendum with it's the Scottish
referendum you're going to have in this
country and now feel the difference so
in this country you have you have a
clear clear a good public debate on the
issue and I think it's done in the
consent of different sides in the Crimea
they have changed the question three
times in six days they have changed the
date of the referendum three times in
six days there is no list of voters all
the Ukrainian channels are turned off in
the peninsula is it really for
referendum so if we talk about
minorities under democracy or without a
democracy that's another good thing to
discuss the way we see the referendum in
Scotland and the way we see the
referendum under no democratic rule of
Russia
potemkin democracy is not democracy
let's be clear we can we can have a vote
a vote does not mean that we're creating
legitimacy that we're creating
government by the people I think one
thing that has fused this discussion so
far has been that we fetishize growth
right authoritarian States authoritarian
States can be good because they can
drive more growth they can create more
jobs they can build the economy growth
is not the only thing that matters in
the world right it is there's no
question that China grows a hell of a
lot faster than India what Martin will
lead you to believe is that means that
their system is clearly superior you
know what if there's a massive shock in
China and there's a massive shock in
India the likelihood that the Indian
system stays stable as opposed to the
Chinese leadership is reasonably high
furthermore the likelihood that we'll
see that kind of shock in China compared
to India is reasonably high - in a
global environment that is massively
more uncertain and volatile and unstable
we will stop fetishizing growth we will
start paying more attention to
resilience and that is why democracy
continues to be the system that we
should be aspiring toward
Martin well I suppose it's I suppose if
you come from one of the richest
countries in the world and certainly the
most powerful country in the world then
to say we're fetishizing growth is well
that's to put it mildly I mean quite
frankly and I'm amazed that you can
speak like that there is or if you are a
poor country if you are a poor people
then the importance of growth is
absolutely fundamental to changing your
circumstances I say I won't accept your
argument in relationship to this I think
that this is absolutely crucial
well I have a similar point and actually
Egypt did not collapse in the face of
its experiment with democracy and the
election of a president that the army
took against and as actually in himself
has argued the army never went anywhere
that's an institution that's a stable
one and it didn't come out of Denia
bankrupt state Egypt at the moment and
democracy is not going to create the
jobs that the Egyptians want from any
government this is the point it's
irrelevant democracy to whether
Egyptians get jobs or not right let's
hear some more voices please from the
middle tell me which way you're voting
please well I started for the motion but
now I'm swaying in between and it seems
that democracies often crumble when
they're faced with 50/50 whoever that's
because the votes are split and this is
due to sometimes splitting ethnicities
or ideologies but a nice history are
shown when this faithfully split they
normally lead in a divided like happened
Ireland now Korea and now this happen in
Ukraine so your question do we have to
accept this divide if democracy your
face were 50/50 thank you okay over
there this is a question for mr.
Shevchenko you're on the platform
speaking in support of the virtues of
democracy and I wanted to know what your
observations were how you felt
about the your opponent if you like mr.
Yanukovych as I understand it a
democratically elected leader being
deposed in what some people would regard
as an undemocratic way elected in 2010
and reapply it is well he was the first
president in the country who gave the
direct order to shoot into his own
people and when he finally realized the
consequences of that decision I think he
was done as a politician so I like the
the definition of democracy which which
Ian presented to us at what what was
done by in the college it was definite
and not by the people and for the people
but you accept that he was
democratically elected of course we use
anymore or as as I said we see a lot of
democratically elected leaders who do
create the things we see mr. Putin who
at some point one kind of a democratic
election and now we see that after
destroying all the democratic
institution he has the power to do any
kind of decisions which mean clear
problems for his neck for his nation do
you think Russia is a democracy no it's
not and I think the terrible things we
wish were witnessing now when Russia is
bringing is taking the world back into
the Cold War era is exactly the
consequence of losing the democracy in
this car even though he was elected in
an election absolutely please
just tell me which way you're voting
please we heard from the proposition
that actually what really mattered for
government was how much power it has but
what we didn't hear was any analysis of
how having the people backing you gives
you more power not only on the
international stage with international
relations but also within your own
country when you're sort of stand out to
global corporations and stuff and I was
wondering whether they should offer us
any discussion on can I immediately
swing in if you look at I believe it's
[Music]
800 million Indians will be voting in
their election coming up or at least how
are entitled to vote over 800 million
where is India at the international
bodies like the United Nations Security
Council
if numbers and democracy count or did
count for your weight in the world about
decisions that defect affect the
fortunes of everybody in the world the
democracies don't get in there the big
ones it's a little one like this one
right let's get some more who's got a
microphone please if tells tell me which
way or which waves against the motion if
democracy is and the best form of
government what is because I don't feel
you should criticize something which you
have no solution to benign dictatorship
could you just say that again what's the
best alternative benign dictatorship we
would all love it until you don't until
you don't please something Martin said
to ear when he said it's easy to say a
comment about growth when you know
you're not from a poor country and in
light of that I just want to ask the
whole panel how well-equipped we even
think we are to have the discussion when
we actually have no representation from
nations from Africa South America or
Asia for instance I think this is a very
very important remark very very
important remark indeed an observation I
agree right
drape I would also add that if you look
at the data on let's say on the African
countries there is a clear correlation
between between democracy and economic
development and once again I strongly
believe that the in the well the Edit
value of democracy is the universal
think across across the world I cannot
find the reason to deprive one or a
different nation from the same standards
that we we are usually applying to the
today to the world which we usually
refer as to as Western world and I would
say that it is not the norm to act
democratically who's gonna lead at the
back the microphone please
undecided but I'm leaning towards
against this long talk about China
tonight I'm Chinese I was born in
Beijing and I've lived there for 13
years and I lived here for 12 years so
I've experienced both systems which do
you prefer
well like I said I'm undecided but
against emotion now so for me coming
from here the definition of democracy
what I experienced this ability to have
an opinion the ability to be able to see
with the degree of transparency what the
government's doing and and to hear both
of the arguments even if you don't like
either so that for me is my experience
of what democracy is so while I may
accept that democracy is not always the
best form of government for China given
our history and tradition
well the panelists accept democracy is
eventually the best form of government
right I now have the result of what you
have decided having listened to this
debate this intelligence squared debate
in London about democracy I remind you
about the emotion democracy is not
always the best form of government I
remind you how you were thinking when
you first came in to this hall before
the debate 44% of you hadn't made up
your mind for the motion 38% against the
motion
18% well almost everyone who didn't make
up their mind at the beginning has now
made up their mind only 3% of you have
not decided that means 40% of you have
made up your mind and I have to report
that after the debate those voting for
the motion were 39% against the motion
58%
by any measure by any measure in this
democratic voting system it was a huge
swing so congratulations to those in and
Andrey who swung all of you 40 percent
of you in their direction and
commiserations to those proposing the
motion Rosemarie and Martin I'm afraid
you lost
our thanks to the speakers to the
audience all of you here at the Cadogan
Hall in London in what's been a
fascinating debate with a remarkable
swing my thanks to intelligence squared
as well for making all this possible
goodbye from me Nik gowing and everyone
here in London bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]